hello and welcome to this video playing
customer when Master shrewder right
should yeah Ricardo Vasquez screwed up
we ever okay no we Lopez get a couple of
rural passes by I was out playing him
and then losing on time I lost I what I
won the odd game yeah this line is
incorrect but you still have to review
it night if I have nice
I cannot remember age 39 f six de 5 d 5
that might be the right one tanks tanks
I think this is some right back okay
okay so let's go there Saudi 5d 585
queen bee five
what is he doing a queen a fall or
something okay so what to do here it
says something better then pawn takes
probably not
so just be six we should be seven I
guess to keep it simple so there should
be six probably for Roxy eight I don't
want them to take it but probably
probably cannot do much about it I'm
Bishop d7 money for night a for things
like that that's possible and some b5
whom not sure if this is how goodness's
but I can just wait a bit or not in a
huge hurry him
with the two bishops I am comfortable
long term anyway so let's see can go be
five here to to open it on night a four
and then be five maybe do that not sure
b5 he can go Queen d3 and it's okay but
not entirely sure
so d5 may be somewhat overloaded I
always have to be carefully it's a good
tactical plan on good form always good
for some tactical shot if he takes I
take you 1 and win the night so he moved
at 25 ok
he had just taking one year for was my
idea oh come on ah really should switch
off the phone before I start to play
okay so he's attacking f7 I didn't see
that f7 was hanging unfortunately come
queen e seven it's not a move I like to
play it seems I had seems a little bit
uncalled needed rookie seven where's he
going after work he is seven actually
back to e3 I guess I spent too much time
spent too much time here oh and then
let's overlook this idiotic Lee simple
move no ah shoot ah what the heck I let
him trick me again yeah he was just in
bad shape you can I have seven as
possible I think threatening night age
six time money doesn't go for it
alright still very difficult because of
my loose pieces I've quindi one Bishop
with sick check check
yes yes yes yes yes didn't see that one
maybe I'm still okay threatening to
promote and he doesn't have a check e 2
yeah my drug might work
so quindi one is going down
check check check check check check
check check check check check how many
moves does he make here like forfeits on
time unbelievable stuff yeah I mean okay
I don't really care about this position
I mean he was like totally lost and then
it's a time scramble Wow yeah really
yeah okay he played one of his trick
openings that really don't work you can
also take on d4 here i think but i think
this is also ok this d5 move leads to a
good position for black because I've got
the bishop and it's fairly comfortable
down the way it was okay so and I went
with this b5 stuff yeah it gets rid of
one of its weaknesses but it opens up
the position it should shouldn't be bad
and it's now got very complicated I
absolutely didn't see Roxy 7 I should go
e seven probably and here i thought just
night f7 but maybe it has a problem and
I thought that would win actually okay
rookie seven still keeping it somehow it
looks more than dangerous okay Queen B 7
was winning though which is fairly
computer ish
I don't even understand the move to be
honest 425 it seems and here I ok again
III winds which I didn't see check
changli so bad which also wins III is
actually right yeah at this I wanted to
be active and 27 I'm winning ok taking
f2 is better of course yeah I just
threatened to promote and then something
like this is fairly easy okay I mean II
to also wins but its twenty seconds
check you all good is just no time at
all Chetty was crazy quick check check
check I mean she crazy quick check check
check check check I just had to pre move
like crazy not to lose on time poor ok
so I'm under fifty percent score against
him ok thanks for watching